all right repeat what do you want to
talk about today
the domestic violence that i witnessed
as a kid between my mom and her
boyfriend
and how it affected me and how it
actually evolved into my relationship
where i thought it was um
actual you know way to live i thought it
was normal
it was so persistent in my household
growing up i
thought that it was a normal thing to do
i thought there was a normal type
relationship a man would have with a
woman
but later i found out it wasn't but
anyway
as a child five six years old
my mother had a boyfriend that uh
he was an alcoholic and i never
really know why the
you know the fighting started between my
mom and him maybe she was telling me to
leave or
i never really remember why but i know
that i was always terrified as a kid
when they would start fighting
we'd be in a room in our bedroom me and
my brothers
and my sisters my mom had 11 children
there were eight boys and three girls
and we're in a two-bedroom apartment and
we made it work
we didn't even we didn't evade each
other's privacy
i mean my sisters were modest and
you know we never exposed or anything
else even
11 of us in one room but my older
brothers
when they would leave my mother
boyfriend would show up and
after a bout of drinking the fighting
was starting to never ruin we always
expected it
and when it started my heart rate
accelerated i mean i knew absolute fear
because i want to protect my mom
so we would run in the room while they
were fighting and
as children six year olds seven eight
nine
we would attack this guy no fear of our
injury to ourself but to protect my mom
so um as we got older and this continued
we got a little bit more aggressive with
the individual who was
you know fighting with my mom to the
point to where
in one particular incident we almost
killed them we were a lot older
anyway um this last
event that i'm talking about my
brothers were my older brothers was 17
18 i was like 13 and
mother boyfriend came to our new place
and as he always do he broke the windows
out when he started breaking the windows
out
my two older brothers attacked viciously
with a hammer and a lead pipe
and i've never really seen a person beat
with a hammer
until this time my brother's literally
chased him down the street for
a long block because i was running with
them behind them
and each time they swung they made
contact
and each contact you'd see just the skin
split open and their blood spray and
for this whole block until the police
intervene somehow they seen it they
intervened and stopped it took both my
brothers to jail
the story unraveled and he broke out the
windows he attacked my mom
and a variety of other things and they
were released
growing up watching these things
i thought it was normal as a teenager
when i got a girlfriend
when i got mad i would get physical with
her
i would literally put my hands on her
i'll slap her hit her
whatever i thought it was a normal thing
to do because i
seen this take place as i grew up i
didn't like it
you know the fact that my mom was the
victim but now
here i am making somebody a victim
so i would hit my son's mother
i would that would really hit her
i wouldn't try and kill her damage but i
still did the wrong thing by putting my
hands on i
really hit her i hit her enough to where
she decided to leave there's a
particular song that says there's a thin
line between
love and hate that was the role that
took place at this particular time
i came home when i was 16 17 we lived
together
i came home and
they were she was taking stuff out of
the house and putting in her mother's
car
and the police were there and i was
aggressive toward the police because as
a
child growing up i mean i i seen a
particular division called 77
division they used to take my brothers
and other people into an
alley and we can be going by and we
would witness
actually watch them pull a person out
the car with handcuffs
in the alley and just beat them down so
we knew what they were capable of
so i was more aggressive as a teenager
for them
thinking i wouldn't let it happen to me
and i was invincible
so when they were there i really got
heated
i found out she was leaving and i could
not understand why
i didn't know why but i asked her could
i talk to her
we moved away and i closed our bedroom
door
they started pounding on it and i threw
the door open and i
almost attacked him but she begged me to
stop and she'd listen to me she told me
she was all right
so they moved down the hallway and we
talked to she told me she was leaving
i learned about love growing up i
learned all the nice things about love
the spongebob things the
holding hands romantic things but i
never knew
that devastating painful side of it
when she left the only thing i could
think of was
suicide and i thought about it a lot for
a long time
a person who wants to commit suicide
doesn't talk to other people about it
you never know that they're going to do
it i researched it
at this time the number one method for
suicide
was self-inflicted gunshot wound
it was with a shotgun and i had one
and it would be in the mouth instead of
under
the chin because under the chin you make
a mess and you're leaving for your
family to clean up
so that was the number one method that i
researched
that people utilized the second method
which was about 92 percent
was um
hanging a person hanging himself they
got to get rid of everybody like robin
williams he made sure everybody was gone
so they wouldn't find them usually they
get found
and they go into a vegetative state the
number three was carbon monoxide
poisoning i
wonder i didn't have a garage
four was sleeping pills
stephen pills have been
made and processed into situation where
you have to take a whole lot up and it
takes a little while
for the effects to take place
the last method the least favorite
method
was um
the plunge jumping from a high
building or high platform
um the way i chose
i thought i would just take a lot of
appeals i chose that way i
figured you'd just go to sleep and you
wouldn't wake up
but uh my mom found out
she i guess she sniffed it out because i
was in this depressive mood i guess she
sniffed it out
and she she found my sleeping pills that
i had purchased and she got rid of him
she told me that if it didn't kill me it
would make me stronger you don't want to
hear that when you're going through it
but
i did i listened i prayed i did
everything that i was told to do and she
didn't come back for a
very very long time
um when she came back
uh well i had been working at tune up
masters shop 12 on pico and lebron
and when she came back i was able to
present it with that that i'd stabilized
that
you know i the violence was going
between me and her
and uh that everything would be okay so
she came back
that lasted about that lasted about uh
another year now this is the event to
where
um i had to put up a few dollars in the
house
and when i went to jail when i went to
prison
prisoners long-term jealous short-term
when i went to prison i never saw a dime
of it but it wasn't the money it was the
boy girl thing that hurt
so um that domestic violence thing was
uh
it changed me it changed me as a person
it changed me because
i don't think i'm who i would have been
had i not gone to this
real suicidal depressive thing it's a
humbling experience
but i also wanted to later
i also wanted to uh i want to aspire i
want to die
there are 33 prisons in california
i've been in 24 of them from pelican bay
to chuckawalla and in each prison i've
been to
i had to do mortal kombat i had to fight
the person
i never worried about fighting the other
races when i got there that was always
in check
the person i had to fight was my own
race they're the first ones to
cross the line with you i didn't
particularly walk the way they walk or
talk the way they talked
i would get i would get the
slang that i thought i was white because
i was using white words i was using big
words well
what i did was take a course in
etymology which is the origin of words
and i got better at being able to
convey my thoughts and a lot of people
didn't like that so
i had to fight at 24
24 prisons 24 i've been in
and i had to fight another black
individual not a white person
not mexican or any other race
another black i really
never had a fight with another race all
the fights i had in prison was with my
own
because of my manner my manner being a
social
i don't socialize my manner of being
taciturn i'm
a quiet individual i don't talk loud
i don't talk to a lot of people out of a
prison with 4 000 people i might talk to
six or seven people
that was enough for me that filled my
quarter
and i could live my life doing i could
live the rest of my time
just talking to a few people um
[Music]
when i finally found that i was getting
out of prison
i was asked what was i going to do
and i said i'm going to go find me a
good bus stop and sit on it and just
watch things go by to me that was a sign
of freedom because
everywhere i've been i was told when i
could when i couldn't when i had to when
i didn't have to
uh for the past 31 years
so this act of freedom was a bus stop
the bus stop i decided to sit on was
skid row i came down here looking for my
younger brother
because he frequented the area he was
the last thing that i had the closest
thing i was to
next to my mom and it took me 18 days to
find him
18 days i would go to every corner every
time i hit a coin and i was shot out of
his name just on the corner people
thought i was crazy i probably
am but i would shout out his name and i
would listen for a reply
18 days later i hit a particular corner
fifth in maine and i shouted out his
name
and i heard somebody say big bro that's
what he always called me
and it was him i turned he ran up to me
i embraced him he embraced me
and that was approximately five years
ago
i've been here ever since i've been here
because
it's easy i've been here because it's
tranquil been here ever since
for the past five years and
i've been here because this isn't just a
death trap this isn't just
the bottom of the world it's just a drug
infested area
this is absolute freedom
freedom from being having to do
something free from being told to do
something
because nobody here really tells you
nothing
they don't tell you when you can use the
bathroom when you can't
when you can shout when you can't
because you don't have to
you don't have to do any of them things
the freedom is so complete to where
i've been placed in a few
homes few buildings apartments
the last one i've been placing for like
i've been there eight days now
i left today i left it because
it's not
the apartment given to me with the
freedom it's a program
i've been in prison 31 years i can't
stand programs i cannot
i can't do a program some people can i
can't the program says that i have to
sign in every day that's a program
the program says that once a week i have
to meet with
a caseworker and a va
representative who's a psychologist or
psychoanalyst and
i kind of refuse to do that i don't want
to do it because then that takes away my
freedom of not having to do it this is
mandatory for me to
keep this room so i gave the room back
i'd rather sleep on a bus stop which is
what i'm going to do
because it's my freedom it's a complete
freedom it's
freedom having to do nothing and nobody
tell you they're making you do anything
i'm uh capable and qualified
to do manual labor i don't mind doesn't
bother me i do a whole lot of it you'd
be surprised how much i actually do
but i want to do it on my terms i do it
five six times a day i maintain a large
area and i maintain it in a
a good decent manner a healthy manner
i left the program because they said i
had to sleep there tonight don't tell
him where i have to sleep that sounds
like prison
telling me where i have to sleep and i
did that for 30. i can't do it another
day i will not do it another day even if
it means not having an apartment and
sleeping on the ground
i'd rather be on the ground because i
don't want to do what you're going to
make me do what you're telling me i have
to do because
if i don't see i mean i can understand
why but if it doesn't make sense to me
i don't want to be the program and they
lay this off on you as though it's not a
program
but i heard the word program several
times today
that i had to sign in but there's no
problem i signed in
that i had to stay there overnight the
longest i stayed in that room was
one minute i went in at 4 47 i left at 4
48
and i never went into the room i just
went in to sign in that's what i do
i didn't want to be a part of a program
i can't do another program
i will not do another program
if i have a choice and i have a choice
i'm
not going to maintain that apartment so
they took it today
well i kind of gave it to them because
they asked me
uh that told me i can't bring a baseball
bat and i said wait a minute
baseball better than the weapon it's a
sport tool
[Music]
well it can be used as weapon i said the
ink pen i've seen jason bourne kill a
man with any penis newspapers or
anything can be used as a weapon
so nobody can bring any pins and
newspapers right he said no where the
bat
is a lot more anyway they asked me to
give it up i told him no
they asked me to give up my knife
pocketknife
i told them no they told me i wasn't
ready for the program
i said hey i didn't know it was a
program i thought it was a you know
living to where i get to do it my way
for at least the next
24 months on my per diem
but they we separated
about two hours ago and
i'll be out and about i'm out and about
because
i don't like to sleep at night i would
see him in the daytime
at night i'd rather just be somewhere be
somewhere to where
somebody in trouble i can help them i
mean i'm not playing superman i know i'm
not i don't think i am
but if i don't help them and i'm there
who else gonna do it
i've seen a lot of situations where
nobody here when i hear somebody scream
female scream i go to it i go towards it
i have to see what's going on
i see a lot of people just stand there
they'll look they'll go about their
business
i can't just look and go by my business
i have to go see what's taking place
because somebody might need help
that's why i'm here my brother
made them had a conversation about why
[Music]
god you know landless and this is
in this uh predicament my predicament
this geographical location
and i know why i'm here i'm here because
i've already helped some people out of
some pretty serious
out of some life and death situations
the last person that i recall helping
was an asian girl named kelly uh
her boyfriend new york you know i
patronized their tent
so when i go to the tent this guy pops
up
and uh he's touching the place
so i step inside the tent and he says
what's up man and he
goes around he leaves so i look around
for a second
he's been in her purse she'd been in
dude's wallet he'd been ransacking the
place
and i look at her and i could see her
eyes rolled up the whites
so i go up to her and i call her name
she don't say that and i slap her
she doesn't move she doesn't even feel
it so i lift her up
her eyes roll back down and her eyes are
fish eyes which means lack of oxygen
i give her cpr for about the next 30
minutes but the first man
i wake him up while i'm doing it and i'm
giving her cpr i'm giving him off the
mouth
and he says yo man what the hell you
doing
i said well either i'm kissing or i'm
giving them out to my one or two
he said i can do that i said well go
ahead breathe for it again
and he didn't know how to breathe he
didn't know that after my resuscitation
process
he blew gingerly he had the blue
forcefully and put air into her lungs he
wouldn't do it so i pushed him to decide
to go get help 20 minutes later amlam
showed up
i had resuscitated her i gave her the
knocking on
what they did was the guy had gave her
she smoked crack
the guy had gave her fentanyl in the
screens this is what they're doing now
she changed her screens the brillo in
her
crack pipe and put brillo that had
fentanyl in it
and when she inhaled the fentanyl
less than 10 minutes later she was in a
cocaine induced coma offending induced
coma
because she was out of it well we know a
large percentage of people who
touch fentanyl die so she literally
died i resuscitated her she came back
she was normal she was real
ginger after that but two days later
somebody did it again i wasn't there
and she died and i consider her a friend
and it
bothers me now that but that's what
they're doing they're giving
fentanyl inside these drugs now and it's
killing a variety of people
around here and everywhere else well
they have fentanyl testers
but they give the way you put it in the
solution and if that's not terms of
particular color
i would advise a lot of people
to get that tester and somebody give you
something or you buy it
test it because the defendant is
designed
well putting these drugs to a dick you
so that you will need this drug from
this person
so they do is they get a turnover base
but a lot of people are dropping dead
because of defending all or maybe it's
the time i don't know
but i pulled back i've counted she was
the 19th person
in five years that i resuscitated down
here
and uh i couldn't and won't be able to
get to everybody
but the ones i can i have
is taking place and
it's a growing sensation because the
ones who live
through the fentanyl get addicted to
fentanyl and they don't want
anything else nothing else will do they
grab it and they hold on to it and it's
the most
addictive thing i've seen in my lifetime
and i've seen some addictive potions
it's a terrible thing
at fentanyl and that's spice they're
both
definitely addicting um
i won't use them i won't give them away
i want something to anybody
they're vicious so anyway uh
i've been here five years and
i'm ready to go
tired of watching movies right around
every corner it's time here to go time
to go back to work and just
get up out of here i mean you don't have
to be far but
it can't be here and i think uh
that if and when i'm able to
interview again it'll be letting you
know that i've left here and i've
settled somewhere else not that i won't
come through because
everybody has to come back to dante's
inferno and try to pull somebody out
like dante did
my time is coming to shine and all my
dreams are on their way
it's time for me to go even if my
brother don't go
i'm leaving i'm out
repeat i hope you make it up you've said
this before
yeah but it's time to go i was hoping
he'd go he left and he came back
i got my place and he came back and i
had this because
my thing was i can't let anything happen
to him he's not going to let nothing
happen to me
but i can't live i'm i'm tired of it i'm
tired of it
because i'm either gonna hurt somebody
or somebody gonna
get rid of me and i don't want either
one to take place so
it's been fun but i'm going to run
next interview if i have one we'll be
letting you know
you know how far i got it's time to go
okay it's good to hear you appreciate it
all right thank you
you're welcome
is this a girl that died